hanging out with all my best friends in
my head and I'm the biggest fan of the
show I was going to say are you a
housewi fan oh it's beyond that it's I'm
actually moderating their Bravo con
panel this weekend in Vegas oh my
go we're partying we're already planning
like dinner spots of the strip to hit up
you know wait speaking of strip you were
you went to my show yes I did I was like
you said you were going to come and then
I didn't know if you really would you
did oh no I was on top of it I bought
tickets to your last show of The
Residency cuz I knew that was the one
that was really going to give I was like
they were all going to give but I was
like I know that you're going to whip
out the classics is is that me sobbing
at your show is that the one wait is
that the one that I did happier than
ever is that the did happier than ever
you did sober yeah that's for real fans
uh yeah and then you did I didn't know
this but so I had of course memorized
the set list before we got by the way I
brought like 13 14 of my friends I'm not
kidding we went as an gay Army to your
show so we went and I had like memorized
the set list and I knew at the end when
you were going to stop before the Encore
so I was like I can go to the bathroom
at this theater the men's room was in
timb two I'm going and I hear just what
if I told you and I'm like she's not
doing a Moment Like This she had never
done A Moment Like This in the show she
surprised did A Moment Like This I peed
faster and harder
and then you were running and I was
sprinting back and also it's like you're
pretty let's say hydrated when you're in
Vegas you know what I mean there was a
lot of stuff that was drunk so I had to
go so bad but I was like let me make it
back for a moments like this and then I
got there and I sobbed I love the video
I know you're so I was really crying
hard anytime you sing I cry oh my gosh
well I never I never sing that one
generally just yeah I know and that's
why I was so surprised you were doing it
because I know you traditionally don't
and so then I was like come on I'm
literally screaming to my friend Patrick
like we have to go we're not washing our
hands like it was I will cop to being
unhygienic when it comes to getting back
if I'm running back in somewhere yes
yeah no it's just or it's usually my kid
at a movie they're like I've got a PR
are you serious I know but you put on
such an incredible show I mean obviously
it was you guys you're you're adding new
shows right you um we are that's
announced right
yes yes we we are we did we added a a
couple I think but um I was like I'm
always like what am I allowed to talk
about I always forget well wait I want
to talk about your Christmas album so
wait did you you did the special I
remember you were saying yeah I just
want to do it I'm going to go out there
and do some Christmas songs it started
as a bit fully I fully hacked the system
and got a record deal so I as a joke in
2017 I'm a comedian I came up here in
New York City and I was just looking to
put like a new show up and I was like oh
I think I saw an interview with Mariah
Carey and the interviewer was like this
is so great like every year you have a
lot to do you have a full schedule I was
like I would like something to do every
year maybe I'll do a Christmas album I
remember you saying this to me yeah and
literally I made it up I was like yeah
I'm doing my Christmas album at the
duplex in the West Village People came
they loved it every year I added to it
now I have a fully original it's top
it's comedy and it's Christmas it's
coming out on Capital Records baby
that's so cool I mean it's unreal and
like I worked with Leland who's this
amazing producer he's worked with Troy
Savon Carrie Underwood Selena Gomez
Kelsey ballerini he never heard any of
those people yeah right just some no
names um but like fully he produced my
whole album and now I look at where life
takes you it's insane and so that's why
I'm saying like you have to fake it till
you make it for real in the biz I said
is manifestation you got to out there
yes it really is because I literally
said the words I have an album as a joke
seven years later I mean look right
there by the way look at that handsome
devil
look thank you we were going for like an
Elvis Presley Vibe we wanted like a very
traditional look to contrast with the
very modern content yeah but it's from
my lens which is not necessarily like
Silver Bells it's more like I have aong
called yeah silver
ball um but by the way so Kelly is
always so thoughtful and the gift that
you give you are the best by the way
because the V she gives every guess
vinyl and she guess like who but I know
that you like Mariah cuz we talked about
Mariah so you came on bow and I's
podcast L and we all like we're guing
over Mariah because we're all in the
lamal right and so she gifted me today
you did the best you you gave me
Mariah's debut album I did wow and so my
gift to you is you can have
that K Clon you can take that home I
love it I love that you have a CHR
record four more shows we I know I
wasn't sure we announced the other two
that's why I I like I was like two or
four on your socials all your shows are
announced you can talk about them toally
and I totally posted that um so we need
another break Matt's album is called
have you heard of Christmas it's out
[Music]
[Applause]
tomorrow you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home